foreign
how's it going folks hey Zane hey gotcha
heyo Ram Faraz Nikolai
D-Day
dinner
420 nerd girl Todd
sea monkey land Jessie
hello hello space Explorer
smiggly smiggoli
Jacob
nerdy all sorts
Dakota it was brilliant solving
Peter hey true sciented welcome back
hey DK
hey Abdul Ali
hey IMAX
sea monkey happy birthday
25th
good stuff once a coward
hello Ruby thank you thank you
hayana rude
hey her funny bones
thank you Frank
I'm assuming uh most people most people
here have beaten the game already
I have not
ever
nothing impressive Jose
off on another adventure is he no
uh waiting for uh PS4 yeah
stream once I've finished with work and
all my errands and going to the gym and
all that stuff
so usually it's pretty late by the time
I
come on to stream and I'm just getting
used to streaming so
there are less people online at this
time and it's a bit uh revelio
less stressful for me
hello again Mr Moon oh
Jesse um I kind of just streamed
sporadically to be honest I should do
consistent days but I'm not doing that
yet
I'll post a schedule at some point
I'm afraid I had rather disconcerting
encounter although I hear your visit to
hoxmead was even more eventful than mine
thanks for dropping by Jacob call it
eventful I I certainly wasn't expecting
well the PS4 release has been delayed
till May really and from what I
understand the village was lucky you
were there
my recent visit to hogsmeade is the
reason I was hoping to bump into you I
could use your help with something
do you see that curious statue over
there
watch what happens when that light
changes from day to night
I read that it was delayed but I didn't
know the day the exact day
you can remove the mood from the statue
odd little Contraptions aren't they it
seems the statue vanishes once the Moon
is removed which incidentally can only
be done at night
why don't you hold on to that one for
now and I'll explain more as we walk
ever since that fateful day in the
village
those curious statues have begun
appearing about the castle
a fair number have been strewn around
um Jesse I would say it would be around
this time yeah
to me you see that day in hogsmeade I
turned a corner and came face to face
with a bogert
or shapeshifter if you will no swamped
off
um I'm playing on uh PS5 this one took
the form you don't know how many guys
[Music]
each other
because I encountered one when I was a
lad in Korea yeah it's great on Facebook
hey everyone those statues are damn it
[Music]
damn it some Jack and apes used a bogart
to learn my greatest fear and use it
against me I have my suspicion as to the
scoundrel all Scoundrels responsible it
is actually do you have a PC copy but I
haven't played it on PC yet
in removing the statues why me I got
early release
frankly uh
funk for fearlessness
second is macabre and idiots or Demi
guys is most would find my fear of them
unwarranted you however have seen how
they affect me I'm at my wits end young
friend I simply can't bring myself to go
near them
in fact I know two steps do you guys
think this game is Canon Tower I only
asked because I just made a video on it
just coming on tomorrow I can go about
my evening I'm curious to see everyone's
opinion
seems all risk and no reward I'll rest
assured out of the best thank you thank
you there is in fact a reward
like is it consistent with existing
Solutions do you think so you'll want to
do that before
it's not entirely a point of view it's
but what's traditionally what's been
published by the author and what's been
endorsed
but there are some exceptions took
advantage of it anyway I've got a video
coming out on it tomorrow
um my opinions and my arguments now
yeah Rita I I agree with you there and
that's part of my video
um steezy do you think it's worth it for
the price absolutely
I choose this camera like I really think
of it a lot explicitly designed to be
open and for fanfic creators to play
with yeah I think so too
foreign
yeah like I I view this as more Canon
than cursed child absolutely
uh I haven't done this yet use l and R
to move the Sparks and rotate the dials
until Bud's Department were activated
really
wait what do I do
use l and R to move to Sparks and rotate
the dials until both corresponding gears
are activated to release the lock
uh
uh I still feel like there's DLC maybe
next year in your sixth year yeah I'm
sure there'll be DLC or just a second
game
but we haven't even gotten the game on a
lot of other consoles yet so
move your analog both left and right and
make a noise and have glow red and green
certain mechanics aren't Canon yeah and
the Elder ones as well contradicts
cannon in this
I think there's a big reason why they
set the game when they did little
interception with the mainstream story
yeah they said it in a really good year
because it's kind of similar enough to
what we know but
not too far away
um and there isn't that much established
canon in the 1800s
I don't
[Music]
the red has a chime noise
let me try this again
foreign
okay so the red is good and now I'm just
the green
oh oh okay thank you
so they glow that's how you know okay
don't make sense
that was embarrassing really long use a
dissolution
pretend you didn't pretend that took me
10 seconds please thank you
[Music]
foreign
exceptional job of keeping the castle in
order they are seldom and prepared for
any number of items that they may
encounter each day however only the
other day an unexpected statute of
Wizarding crackers went off from behind
a cushion the cacophony was most up
untoward
engulfing one poor elf in blue smoke and
giving those of us nearby an abominable
ringing in our ears the rest of the day
thieves
Rebellion
I don't like this Quest I don't I don't
feel like doing this it's hard to
focus on this and
chat and play this
I'm just gonna do a side quest
do I fake my British accent no
um but it is watered down because I live
in Canada so
it's not 100 anymore
they need peeves
what am I even doing in this retrieve
the Demi guy's moon in the prefix
bathroom
yeah well if I go to England it'll come
back completely
um but you know I don't interact with a
lot of English people
um and I moved here when I was young so
the result is a bit of a mix
which sort of gets stronger depending on
who I've been interacting with
so if I interact with more Canadians it
sounds more canadiany and then if I go
to England or I'm with English people it
sounds more English and no I am not Star
Wars Theory he's a partner on the
channel but I am not him
uh
IGA 18
thank you thank you
Muhammad
um I lived in Somerset
I was born in Taunton
uh Loki how come we never see you in the
same room there's a photo of us on the
HP Theory Instagram
the two of us
DBC I don't know what you're talking
about
no
come on guys
we don't have the same voice I don't
I don't understand when people say that
we sound similar but we don't we don't
sound the same
he has a terrible terrible English
accent
he thinks it's good
no no no I'm not a trick pony
I'm not doing accents on demand
you say that every year Matilda
hi Jasmine
hey smiggly I guess I'll just I'm sorry
I'm on the fence about doing this Quest
but I guess I should just do it I mean I
don't want to do it really
is the uh the problem I just don't care
about this quest for some reason
yeah I'm not really I'm not really
focused I just came on to to have a bit
of fun and uh
this Quest needs a lot of focus
um
thank you thank you Luca
[Music]
alohomora
there we go
I haven't beaten the game I have um one
more character which is a little bit
ahead that I've used offline but
I'm not much further
she's right
now stressful
Muhammad why are you asking me these
questions
well all of the teamwork and uh flying
about and the golden snitch
rather a lot like that
oh no
this is stressful
hey Vogue
bombardo I think is the spell to use
here yeah I agree hey fell foot hey
Lakota 21.
he doesn't look like he can run past
them it's quite sketchy
oh I made it
my goodness
I can't wait for this quest to be over I
don't like this I don't like this
sneaking stuff
I'm not good at it
hey Jamshed
hey Lucas
thank you
well if I'm trying to sneak I can't
really read the chat so it's not really
conducive to good uh
streaming
I always feel guys
hey Darth Deus hey Aaron
there we go
looking so bad
hey Joshua
am I almost done is it is that it
is that all the sneaky
the moon I have the moons you asked me
to collect oh goodness you're excellent
if you guys enjoyed these live streams
please give it a like the previous
caretaker a secret
to discover the identity of my torment
Jesse
oh
not Hey Jessie goodbye Jesse have a good
night thanks for uh tuning in
I didn't even read that what did he say
what quest is this
I'm fairly busy I can't promise anything
um
but I hope you will find the time in
case it matters no I haven't reached
that exchange for your assistance
now remember the Moon
thus I encourage you to use a
disillusionment I'll try and do more of
these I was I was doing them more
consistently um for a little bit when
the game came out but uh I haven't even
beaten the game so
understood I shall keep an eye out I
appreciate that
yeah I'll do this one later
what's a quest that I can do right now
that's fun or something I can do right
now that's fun
uh yeah I play in my free time at night
exactly
find a unicorn
yeah the robotic voice is a bit strange
I assume that'll get patched
I mean it doesn't bother me that much
but
it'd be cool if they fixed it
you might change your mind about the
Elder one breaking Cannon once you play
the third trial okay I'm curious to see
what you mean by that I mean I do have
to beat the game because right now I'm
uninformed and they want to make videos
on the game
um but I also don't want to just pout
you know plow through it
which uh yeah which Quest should I do
what's what's a fun one
someone is caught okay
questions
around Mrs Hopkins
he hasn't been himself Sebastian just uh
sent me an hour
okay I'll go do Sebastian's Quest
perfect timing
look at all these owls
I guess you get owls when you finish
main quests right
he says just south of Hogwarts
can I go this way
where is this
oh my goodness this is so far away
foreign
it's cool I'm into this
what's everyone's uh favorite part of
the game without
spoiling anything for those who haven't
played yet
oh that's a good point maybe I should
check the flu flames
I'll go there
I gotta I gotta get this flu I gotta get
the flu
you think Molly used expulsa and
Bellatrix yeah maybe
yeah I do like flying around though I
will say
resource indeed your field guys
I think they'll be quidditch in some
kind of
oh can you revelli on the Broom okay
let's get the next one
set a waypoint
you can use ravelli on the Broom the
part the beat of The Bard row flying
rule around Hogwarts Castle
and then my character malice Blackheart
hold it with the Harry Potter Universe
good yep absolutely
man I love how expansive they made this
game because they could have just really
easily kept this
within the confines of Hogwarts
hey NICU
niku
I think my least favorite part of the
game are these uh quests where you have
to sneak around
but it's not a huge complaint because
that is kind of part of Harry Potter
revelio
seems a pleasant enough little place
here we go
love this I haven't done this yet love
this
my my
oh I have to go to the room of
requirement as well soon
oh what
okay now he's alive literally died
yeah my talents are not completely
allocated yet because I've decided to
wait until I have a good understanding
of them
so I've got like five unused Talent
points or something we made it
the first time I did a spider cave in
the Forbidden first had to pause to cry
yeah
enjoying the view keeping an eye on
things
feldcraft isn't what it used to be no
one has felt safe here since ran Rock's
loyalists took a peculiar interest in
that castle over there Rookwood Castle
my uncle Solomon is a former Aura and
refuses to look into it even after Anne
was cursed by one of them possibly with
a wand no less I heard a goblin refer to
wizard kind as warned carriers
a Goblin's forbidden from carrying ones
precisely that's why I'm on the hunt for
answers if I'm secure I need to
understand what happened to her Anne was
always the most mischievous of the three
of us
which is saying something knowing neon
ominous
I'm hoping a surprise visit from me and
a new friend from Hogwarts will help
lift her spirits
bring back the Anna I Used to Know come
on I'll take you to my uncles
oh this way
interesting
felcroft used to be a lot livelier
with randrop's lot wandering about all
the time everyone stays out of sight
here we are my sister should be just
inside
looks like a hobberton
Sebastian where did you
is that what I think it is we've been
over this boy shrivel figs cannot
reverse a curse
nothing can
the sooner you accept that reality the
better
but we haven't tried everything there is
when will you accept that never
I can never accept it
what you've done
I'm sorry oh
ah
I'm sorry you had to see that if you
don't mind I just need a moment alone
ask me to come here and then uh once a
moment alone nice
hey come all the way come all the way
out here and then
needs a moment alone that boy will frame
my last nerve my goodness
excuse me Mr Salo oh yes Sebastian's
friend I apologize on behalf of my
nephew he doesn't know when to stop
he thinks he can help Anne but nothing
can be done for her
it could be that you've not yet
discovered the Cure
then the healers at some Mongols perhaps
the healers don't know everything sir
Steven is single-mindedly focused on
finding a way to help his sister
if there is a cure
he will find it your faith in Sebastian
has misplaced some sort of dark magic
cursed and and the Goblins aren't likely
to explain themselves anytime soon what
cures does she have on her I don't know
the only thing to do now is keep and do
you find that out in the game
I want you guys to spoil it I don't know
I understand what you're saying
I know what's best for Ann
a if you really want to be of help he's
no I
I hope you'll remember what I've said
good day
I'm sorry about her Rebellion there's
bounds of pain are difficult to bear
Sebastian this is my potion kit not
yours leave my things behind
I didn't mean to intrude you didn't
truly I
am all right the pain from this curse
comes in okay yeah please don't spoil it
often suddenly it is not anyone's fault
it's nice to meet you by the way you
must be the new fifth year Sebastian
told me about I am Sebastian and I met
on my first day at Hogwarts in the
Slytherin common room oh
First Years
of Hogwarts but I wouldn't mind being at
Feld Croft really if it wasn't so dreary
now between the Goblins at the castle
Yeah
it's not the Cozy Retreat it once was
Sebastian mentioned something about your
uncle being an ex-ora but refusing to go
after Round Rock's loyalists I must say
I wasn't prepared for him to be as angry
as he was Uncle Solomon is frustrated by
what happened to me and by Sebastian for
thinking he can fix it they both mean
well I know they do but my uncle is
right this curse cannot be undone I can
feel it Sebastian cannot take away my
pain
perhaps you can help him to understand
that
I'm afraid it's really up to Sebastian
and his mind seems to be made up I can
only
hides as the futility of his search for
a cure soon I'm getting tired I should
probably rest thank you for stopping by
I wish you well I ought to see how yeah
I need to play through as a Hufflepuff
because I really want to see Azkaban
that'll be my next playthrough I think
to me
Lister
how are you doing Sebastian and glance
of what I'm dealing with
I apologize for my uncle
I'll admit I wasn't expecting him to be
so angry he's always angry
he's been angry since my parents what
have you guys or after ran was played
through on so far as though he blames me
I've got two slytherins which is calling
me my Father's son that's an insult
either I'm trying to help her
simply given up but
your uncle seem genuinely convinced that
nothing more can be done for her I
refuse to believe that Anne's pain is
more than physical it has changed her
entirely I miss my sister
how many hours have you logged
Round Rock's loyalists are capable of so
much more than people realize they
should not be underestimated
evil Ravenclaw whatever you'll see is
from whatever's going on
Ravenclaw have the powerful movement
will be my next playthrough up there on
that plateau
is where they curse Dan oh my goodness
this way
what's the exclusive quest for
PlayStation
260 hours oh my goodness
[Music]
thank you
son of a gun
s
coming back this way Rusty
oh my goodness look at that
you've made your last mistake do I have
confringo twice oh my goodness
that makes sense I didn't even realize
that's ridiculous
um I thought I had Expelliarmus
thank you for pointing that out
is during that Quest you're wasting a
spell
there we go
wasn't so bad I confessed that was a bit
smaller than I'd bargained for Okay so
we've got
do you know about the Avada cadaver
multi-kill combo no I finished some
Platinum the game at around 160 hours
an exclusive quest for PlayStation is a
shop you can get in Hog's meat is really
not that great in the air Xbox will get
it too
bro it's 4am
that's right Dave
not for me though
thank you thank you
yeah that wasn't so bad
thank you dub Webb
heck yeah
those loyalists deserved what they got
couldn't agree more
this is where it happened yeah it's 117
for me as well when we looked outside
Flames were shooting from the estate
before my uncle and I could stop her and
rushed out racing towards the fire
worried so my boss was a bit
underwhelming she came face to face with
a horde of goblins frantically trying to
Stamp Out the Flames suddenly an icy
voice drifted out from somewhere in the
smoke
children should be seen and not heard
a blinding blast followed they didn't
even give her a chance to run
it sounds as if the Loyalists attacked
them without cause I wouldn't put it
past them
but I'm convinced that they were trying
to hide something it may be grasping at
Billy wigs but I keep thinking that
there might be something here that could
lead me to whoever cursedan might be the
only way to learn what type of magic
harmed her you guys enjoy the stream
you're right
everywhere but they do seem to be
spending a lot of time here and it's
likely their height and at Rookwood
shall we have a look around
they seem to have said
collections
anything unclaimed
Maybe
no
should I get this
is this worth it
Emma 9 18 a.m thought we might be
England
no no I live in uh I live in Canada but
I'm from England
yeah okay I'll get this
anything else in here I should get in
the in the core
any of these
core and spells
make use of your points in mostly core
and spells in this stage
uh Vancouver yeah
protego stuff is really good I think
I'll just wait I'll have to to research
this a bit I don't want to make mistakes
because I've heard that you can't Max
everything out right
is this good
is this worth getting
I use IQ a lot
oh levioso mastery
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do that
okay I'll leave this for now I'll leave
this for now
specific reason
they have stations
always armed and ready for a fight Round
Rock's loyalists
oh there we go
I've heard the goblin dig sites like
these are popping up evalio
hmm
it's a wonder the ministry isn't doing
more whose home was this
bit abandoned long since I've lived here
don't buy any room of requirement skills
you can afford them all okay
but that's all I ever heard
it might be worth taking a closer look
at the house it's 41 points total okay
I like this Rebellion master I must say
this is quite nice
revelio
this well looks familiar
Sebastian
I've seen this before
this house the well the view what do you
mean when give me a moment I'll explain
in a second
rebellio
Sebastian
over here
do you think that this was damaged by
the fire the night the animals
could be
but it looks to me as though this was
intentional
Sebastian this house did belong to a
Hogwarts Professor hundreds of years ago
who what do you found a pensive that day
in the Restricted Section with a memory
that showed this house there was a
little girl and a drought the keepers
have shown me other memories as well the
girl became a Hogwarts professor
her name was I don't like how easy it is
to customize how everything looks I wish
you had to Source items were powerful
but looked a certain way and you found a
pensive in the library
I'm not following you I realize it's a
lot to take in I'm not even sure I
understand it all yet
and no
not like quidditch they call themselves
Keepers because they're protecting some
type of knowledge
it has to do with the Vault gringolds
let me see if I've got this straight you
have ran Rock and Rookwood after you
because of something you found at
Gringotts where you ended up via a Porky
and now you've been witnessing memories
left by keepers
oh and this house belonged to a Hogwarts
Professor who was one of these
non-quidditch Keepers hundreds of years
ago if I didn't know you I think you
were pulling my leg it is all a bit much
isn't it when you put it like that
the point is we both have good reason to
search this house you for answers about
what happened to Anne and Me For answers
about the kids yeah I know that's megali
but I don't like that
I wish that wasn't a thing it makes it
too easy for a reason
is it blocking something only one way to
find out
huh a stairwell
uh yeah it's my first playthrough why
bother blocking
here
they've left all of this simply strewn
about
tells me they're after something bigger
I traveled here to learn I long to help
my internal struggles overwhelming it's
as though the magic wants to heal and
I'm the one preventing it from doing so
should I lose hope will I forever regret
not having done more I cannot look into
their eyes knowing that I could lessen
the burden of Heartache I saw the man
leaving camp today the one who so
reminded me of my father surely wouldn't
hurt to help him I could further my
research of course but that would be a
fortuitous consequence of doing
something good with disability
seems these journal entries are from
isadora's travel
here he is
jar jar gaunt
the myth The Man legend
which Harry Potter franchise
which franchise
what stuff do I have
oh
thank you thank you I mean
that'd be nice I did a sponsorship with
uh Warner Brothers for this game which
was uh exciting for me
oh my goodness look at him now
hey Lauren
look at this hat folks
what do you think
is this it
splits uh that's what I was hoping to
avoid
I've just been taking my time
hey Daniel
there's no rush peace and games
just enjoy it
journal entry of his adores
should hold on to this
you're not going to believe this
I can see the undercroft
a Daydream
[Music]
I know it sounds strange but honestly
nothing you say sounds strange to me
anymore fair enough
I can see the undercroft through this
I'm listening I have a rare ability to
see Whispers I don't know what I was
expecting you to say I'm not entirely
sure but the keepers have said you can
just wear pajamas really that should
only be wielded by a selector and you
can wield it I don't know
fig and I think that ranrock has somehow
found a way to harness that Magic's
power are you telling me that goblins
may be wielding some that's what we're
trying to what I do know is them wait
we we can
but perhaps best not to tell understood
I'm tempted to hold my breath let's go
I like this Quest this is cool
one of my favorite quests so far I think
why would the door lead us here
Sebastian sleepy noodle have you beat
the game I have not
milk I get quite bored of streams easily
but watching this new talking is quite
enjoyable thank you bye uh
aspire to be interesting on the stream
I'm still getting used to it
still not super comfortable with it
seems as if something's missing
let's have a look
examine the notes
ah yes of course
anything helpful in the note
a rune symbol
I've seen similar symbols used by the
keepers I've been thinking my character
looks ridiculous lived in that house
centuries ago
in his lot have been searching there he
looks like that starts talking about
ancient magic ancient Magic
do you think Anne was cursed by I can't
be sure of course but hmm
very well
but that doesn't mean it's not true
then we'll have to unravel what this all
means did I mention that apparently
Salazar Slytherin had a secret
scratorium here in Hogwarts you did not
no idea ominous just learned of it I had
no idea our visits
I'll be in touch
till then is that it
oh
this game is my well spent 60 Euros yeah
it's definitely worth the price
um
just gonna pretend you with a group good
a little bit a group of good friends
playing fun game yeah it's true
looking like the Jesse Ventura of The
Wizarding World ominous is the homie yep
first time watching your gameplay what
house you sorted in uh I'm in southern
I've actually got two Slytherin
characters that are similar levels which
is pointless but uh there you go
hey young butter
lumos
Rebellion
yeah yeah I know I can change the look
of the stuff
I just I'm just embracing it
this looks like how Dobby would dress if
he were a wizard
[Music]
revelio
what am I doing now
what's the follow-up to this this
what should I do now this one
the elf
conjuration do I want that
I think so
is it a good Quest
all right let's meet with Deke
can I get an rip Dobby in the chat
oh cool
The Forbidden Forest are you trying to
get your Rebellion
Rebellion
I'm enjoying this uh new revelio range
very much
this was well worth
points
off on another adventure are we
almost couldn't bring them
revelio
Oliver hello hello
Daniel it's my birthday today glad to be
joining with yourself hey happy birthday
how old are you
foreign
which birthday is it
big one small one
Rebellion
23rd very nice
Aloha Mora I love this a lot more I must
say
Marco did you finish the game yet nope I
haven't finished the game
oh very nice Celtic
brush stroke scarf Dear Professor Shah
thank you for your recent submission
regarding Celestial anomalies it may be
a perfect addition to an atlas I'm
hoping to publish I should be in touch
if I decide to include your submission
or any of its related research in the
publication best wishes ypn carner car
near us
um the disillusionment charm is not the
same as the invisibility cloak the
invisibility cloak will be much more
effective the disillusionment charm
allows you to
sort of resemble your surroundings like
a chameleon
and the invisibility cloak just makes
you invisible
if I remember correctly at least
all that for a leather flat cap
what's this cat doing in this locked
room
any any answers to that
anyone
whose room is this also
Rebellion
it's his house would I break in is the
question that is the question I think
ah dick is so happy to see you in deep
notice this bag in the room the other
day you must need it to help with your
schoolwork
dick has seen one of these before Dick
calls it a knapsack
cat bessing Sim 2000 yeah you gotta pet
the cats guys
I don't think you got 100 in the game if
you didn't pet the cats Gathering and
transporting beasts
I've been thinking about something
Professor Allen said in vista's class
that I should study as many beasts as I
can on my own time she also mentioned
that poachers have been active in the
area
you sleep you see the room knewings
come along then
yeah love Deke
if you don't pet every cat in the game
or you can come and find it easy to go
oh
okay
okay oh my look at these hmm
very fancy
foreign
spoiler-free content for later Harry
Potter movies would be great
yeah it's kind of
I just get where you're coming from but
it's kind of hard to avoid
spoilers in videos talking about such an
old franchise
like I haven't ever approached my videos
from like a
spoiler-free perspective because it's so
old
yeah if you don't pet every cat you
didn't really play the game properly to
be honest
um but yeah ammo like if you're
selective or you know some of the videos
just discuss particular movies
um or books
so that's one way of kind of trying to
filter through them but
I'll uh I'll think about it I'll think
about how I can approach that
your character looks like a grandma yep
absolutely
headwear
look at this thing wait for this
oh
okay young Buster I Theory got work
early I'll catch you vegetarian more
often thanks for joining
I'll try and be on here more often
do you think they'll ever make a Harry
Potter TV show
um yeah I'd like them too I'd really
like a show on the founders or the
Marauders or Tom Riddle origins or Snape
Origins I think those are my top picks
um I think it'll happen but
who knows how long that's going to take
I think the interest in this game
will help to sort of reignite
um the passion for Harry Potter in
general and I think we'll get some more
content out of Warner Brothers now
is this your first playthrough uh yeah I
have two characters but neither of them
are very high level
you should do a discussion video on
Sebastian's family yes yes I will I'll
do all the
um Family Lines
I did a video history of the gaunt
family the other day and I I included
ominous so I'm considering the game
canon as of now
and I think I'll probably stick with
that opinion I'm going to include this
stuff in the videos moving forward but I
will make that distinction
I'll take a medieval Wizarding World
show to be honest a whole new era yeah
that'd be cool too
Merlin
giorgos yogos
recently found your channel I'm a big
fan of your theories thank you very much
Oliver another rings of power situation
would be horrible was rings of power bad
I haven't watched it
I mean I thought was wasn't HBO supposed
to be making a Harry Potter TV show did
that get canceled
um
there those announcements are always
being made on the internet doesn't mean
anything honestly
I think it's like news Publications when
they have nothing else to write about
they make a click bait title about Harry
Potter
I'm ready to learn how to use the knob
sack
perf outing I'm glad that Disney
don't own it
have you considered teaming up with
Harry Potter folklore for video collab
uh we've talked about it before but just
hasn't really happened
I like his channel though
a nasty poacher
this was nice thanks are you living just
a beautiful beasts my arms World hi
hello
days that Deke first saw and knabsack
it'll be nice raise the power was bad
for good
yeah I mean I don't want Disney taking
control
no no no no Warner Bros should keep it
quality not quantity guys
we have arrived
we can enjoy his rings of power worth
watching especially though if I like
Lord of the Rings nearby it would be
nice to keep them safe all you will need
to do is also if you guys like get rid
of the Rings
the YouTube channel it's got he's got
good stuff
leave the poor creature alone
um
Warner Brothers would never sell her
across Disney no I don't think they
would
have you been on a postureless podcast I
have not
Daniel you have really strong
feelings about rings of power
my goodness
I managed to rescue a puff skin you can
rescue as many as the knapsack will hold
poachers capture puff schemes and well
dick isn't sure what they do with them
dick is certain they will be safer with
you can you now capture any Beast simple
to rescue that lives in a den with that
Beast icon next find a beast that can
fly a job at Knoll perhaps all right
where would I find one is that the idea
reserve some to the West nesting in a
large tree overlooking Hogwarts
must be careful they could have seen
poachers in the area recently dick will
meet you there whenever you're ready
okay I'm definitely gonna go do this
because can I fly this thing
your character looks like mine
hello Deek should we continue hi Vincent
Deke was worried about you what with all
the poachers in the area perhaps we
should work quickly the oh my
controller's dying let me plug it in if
it's helpful Deek has seen levioso use
two slow flying beasts easier to get in
close and use the knabsack
then I shall go and rescue a job and all
good luck he could be waiting
control is charging now
um
that wasn't so bad
that was it
oh
I rescued a Japanese Deke hopes your job
and all finds the knapsack nice and cozy
poachers want them it's not my first
stream but it's like my this is my ninth
stream on the channel in four years we
started the channel in March of 2019 so
we're just about to hit our four-year
anniversary dick will see you there
do I have to do this 10 times with him
yeah
hello Deke is this the clearing you
mentioned it is the cars gather near the
large tree with the spiral pattern in
front but only do you guys want the moon
Fantastic Beasts for are you done with
it because I think you have a way to
haste and time your mind sometimes
yeah I I want it but
I don't know I think they were improving
gradually did you guys like those films
what would you rate them give me the the
ratings one two three
Pato tato you sub oh you subbed three
years ago my my
welcome back
I give the first Fantastic Beasts 6.5
I give the second 6.75 I give the third
a seven
but
given that I'm a Harry Potter fanatic
those aren't that high
and I did like Maz he was good
I don't love changing actors mid movie
but
I think Mass did a good job
I shall go and find a moon cough then d
we'll be waiting the most recent one is
the best one
sorry how do I um Advance time it told
me how to do it but I forgot
you give the second one three sleepy
noodle
my goodness
foreign
thank you
why do you give the second one a three
what was so much worse about it
no you don't
oh my goodness
there we go
look after you
I like that it says rescue a moon cough
like I'm rescuing it
I don't think I'm doing that
yeah why would you why would you give it
a three I'm curious
I think eight is high
for those films
it was a bit trickier than the others
but I have a moon cough now another
Beast safe and sound shame we didn't see
the moon calves dancing it's a marvelous
sight big surposes you're finished here
you'll be able to rescue many more
beasts but for now let's bring the ones
you've gathered back to the room all
right take will meet you back in the
room whenever you're ready
return to the room
oh my goodness look at these big boys
silver spectacles
oh my my
yeah I've made lots of videos about the
financial system in the Wizarding World
I did not think the fight between
Dumbledore and Grindelwald was good
nothing happened
do I do YouTube full-time yes I do
luckily
I didn't at first but a few years into
the channel I made the switch
because we know what happens yeah I
don't know if it makes it that Matt
because there's we don't know everything
so
there's still lots of voids to fill
the ending is really bad it's just
completely flashback after complete
flashback
Newt being the main character
yeah I don't love Newt as the main
character to be honest
favorite book
um
I'm always partial for the first book
just because of the Nostalgia aspect I
don't think it was necessarily the most
entertaining but
I liked um Goblet of Fire
what are you up to now
revelio
lumos
I mean
Wood opening the Chamber of Secrets and
Hogwarts Legacy break Cannon no because
it could have happened and then no one
knew about it I mean I guess
but it's kind of a lame way of excusing
it
my fears are going to use World War II
heavy than remaining fantastic Beast
movies and nothing with the Beast
themselves I don't really care about the
beasts in those movies to be honest I
just want the Dumbledore storyline
that's the main reason I like I want to
watch them
and I think Jude Law does a really good
job
big fan of him
don't care about and you don't really
care about the beasts if I'm honest
laughs
I wish you could zoom out
it's so zoomed in handy resource indeed
I'm most pleased I hate how zoomed in it
is
hunting Ashley
okay you've no idea who I am but I've
been binging your Harry Potter videos
for two weeks now
so we'll [__] listen to oh
thank you very much
excuse my language
models did hilarious mods for this game
like San Andreas
yeah it's so zoomed in it's like
uncomfortable I always feel
claustrophobic
like I wish I could zoom out there you
are we need to show the Beast you
rescued their new home
but um not enough room to let them out
here imagine all those beasts running a
mock that wouldn't do it all
perhaps if you focus on what your beasts
need the room will provide
you can't change field of view on PS5
what exactly did you think of
I think that's just on PC and stuff
make my life a lot easier if I could
[Music]
sure
only one way to find out
make you win yeah hopefully they've
patch the field of view thing
I will be right back to gonna get a
drink hold on one minute what 30 seconds
foreign
no this is my
ninth string
um I did a bunch when the game first
came out
what are my opinions on this game I love
it I mean I haven't beaten the game so I
haven't experienced everything but
settings wise I'd like field of view and
then
um there might be a playlist
I can't remember I think I think I made
one
I think it's called the Hogwarts Legacy
live or Harry Potter live streams or
something like that
I'd like to ask you about changing
of course yeah what sort of hold on let
me see if there's a playlist one second
I think I made a playlist
um
yeah I have a playlist called
Harry Potter streams
uh do I wish I could play this game
online against other people yeah of
course
that can never hurt I mean I like I like
the way it's set up but
foreign
for years I love everything except for
the ending I don't know the ending yet
but I've been waiting for years as well
um
maybe one day if they bring new Harry
Potter film they can super enhance
Professor snakes faced with the original
actor Snape's face yeah yeah
why not
load Tobias
uh my name is Silas
I've got it in some videos
HPT or Silas whatever you want
online quidditch yeah
Adam Driver would be great
it's uh lemon sparkling water
I got some pineapple as well
um okay
mine actually perhaps another time
I do like uh some soda though shout out
to xevia if anyone drinks that
xevia ginger root beer very nice it's
amazing amazing where are we dick
beasts to live a viberium of some sort
oh your Beast will be quite comfortable
here they'll live healthy safe lives
perhaps you want to release them let
them see their new home
based thank you
sparkling motion Harry Potter truly a
man with taste thank you thank you
what country are you from I'm from
England
but I live in Canada
it's uh s-i-l-a-s
magical Ministry of Legacy yep Ministry
of magic
oh nice
cousin's name is Silas interesting
don't meet a lot of silences
does this break the law of the room of
requirement having an entire world
inside of it nah not really
it's just like news uh suitcase be a
fitting new home for your beasts indeed
I only hope we'll have enough space for
all of them dick hope so too but if you
do run out of broom Madame Peck at
brewed and Peck in hogsmeade will help
to find safe homes for them any Beasts
of the room can't hold yes she is well
known for helping to care Diagon Alley
would be an amazing experience
for them speaking of care beasts that
are well fed and groomed if you gather
some magical material very well
[Music]
thank you
foreign
lucky puff skin
they will eat the same food is that what
that was happening
can I give some to Deke
yeah this is basically a tardis isn't it
hey guys if you enjoy the stream please
give it a like
so that I know to do more of them
St mongos
I've been to Harry Potter land at uh
Universal Studios that was fun
but I haven't been to any of the other
ones
I gotta go
oh I better get
fur and things okay I see
brush them
wonderful
where's the
puff skin
and they're feeding the ourselves
12 beasts and bavarium four species
going is there one in Singapore didn't
even know that
very nice I collected some magical
materials dick now Deke can show you how
to use them first you'll need to use
this spellcraft to conjure an invest the
train station which is in Yorkshire down
the road from the exactly TV programs
I used to watch heartbeat magic into the
very threads of you did you watch it I
watch it with my parents
why don't you try it big things you'll
be impressed with what the loom can do
just live in Bedford and I live in
Australia very nice
I'm from Japan have you visited our
Harry Potter park at our Universal
Studios I haven't I'd like to go to
Japan though
[Music]
this
mooncalf this is a moon cough
I think I need a third
spell set for these
these ones
oh
is it worth it to get the third spell
set
yes or no
Hello Olivia welcome
okay I'll do that
uh what is that in core
right
there it is
look at me
this will be my
pet spell set
thank you
Enchanted
blue
oh my goodness uh
uh where do I put it
um
over here
stuff in here
oh it's horrible
is it worth it to upgrade
this stuff right now or no
well I'll do this just for the quest
what am I wearing
golden silk robe let's upgrade this
okay it's telling me to upgrade an item
of clothing
nice
I came out nicely
I should show dick
yeah you can customize the room however
you want
there's too much to do I find it I have
a hard time staying in one spot in this
game
yeah let's do that
vote to decide if the game is Canon or
not
I'm doing sorry I've done a video on
this it's coming out tomorrow
I'm up with my opinion
foreign
wonderful would I be able to weave even
more powerful magic into my clothing at
the loom you will by rescuing even more
powerful beasts for now however deep
suggests you explore the vivarium and
get to know the Beast you've already
rescued
uh the video is going to come out
in what at 1pm Pacific time it'll come
out
okay
thank you for your help Deke
I did sort of like a Canon tier list
within that video as well
[Music]
yeah 4 P.M eastern time yeah
yes yeah the video is done it's it's
scheduled
I think I just have to make a thumbnail
actually
true sighted that's what I think as well
yeah I don't think
I don't think they had total autonomy
and they nailed nuances of this game
that I'm sure they had to
you know
confirm through someone
what am I doing now
let's do
meet nasty
after Dark
can I do that now
where is this
which uh which Quest is this
oh let's do this yeah yeah big time this
is the one
foreign
broadens the mind
anything to do with the dark heart
should be avoided it's too risky
anything to do with Salazar Slytherin is
working
I
Won't Give Up
foreign
speaking about he's being ridiculous
apparently Salazar Slytherin had a
secret scriptorium here in Hogwarts I
want to swears it was used for the dark
arts so he wants nothing to do with it I
reminded him that Anne need to cure this
scriptorium could hold the answers we
need
the dark arts do pique my interest
there's more to dark magic Than People
realize cursed child is terrible better
than most
JK Rowling already established his
family history is personal to him jonin
hello big fan thank you Jonah
hello hello
I'd like to know more about it if you
wouldn't mind telling me I won't repeat
it hello Force Lord welcome please like
the stream guys if you enjoy Magic from
his parents thank you thank you
are you familiar with the cruciatus
curse
what does the cruciatus curse do it's
known as the torture curse crucio
it inflicts intense excruciating pain on
the victim apparently his parents and
older siblings did you say crucios or
crucios he's saying crucial
so the first time he was asked to cast
it himself as a child
couldn't bring himself to do it Rihanna
just realized I'm not subscribing you've
got to subscribe the anguish was so bad
that when Austin Mr Green Love In The
Stream thank you thank you I have
repeatedly assured ominous crucial yeah
yeah he still hasn't forgiven himself
thinking straight when you've been hit
with crucia after that incident the rift
between ominous don't love that though
this is crucial that is until I came
along every moment he isn't Hogwarts
he's with us in feldcroft I want his
trusts me and more often than not he
winds up listening to me I'll remind him
of that when I follow up about the
scriptorium watch for my owl I'll have
news soon enough
I'll make ominous understand I say hello
in his mind
he's really pronouncing that sh
it yeah no I don't love the cursed child
revelio
Rebecca there liked it before you
enjoyed playing love your videos keep up
the awesome work thank you thank you
appreciate that
I haven't spent any time in the Great
Hall at all
[Music]
huh
Jim Dale doesn't say everything right
but I'll accept that
depends on where you're from yeah
I think so
revelio
my major Harry Potter fan yeah
absolutely
it's my dream job
love this
how nice to see you my young
um yeah
[Music]
Nia AKA theory he started the Channel
with me
so he's still affiliated
I mainly do things now but he he's
helped up he's helped out a lot along
the way
revelio
Vincent what do you think of what
I'm uh I'm happy my videos helped
and if you guys have questions
um about the law
always leave a comment in in on my
existing videos because I always read
the comments
leave a comment on my most recent video
If you have a question and that's that's
your best bet
uh I get hundreds of comments on the
most recent videos but
you know I look at them
if you leave a comment in the first kind
of two days the videos up that's the
best bet
often another adventure Ollie
or you can message me on Instagram HP
Theory
and I'll take requests there as well
if you guys don't follow me on Instagram
go do it
let me answer
you better keep an eye on high places
around the school for zenobia's
gobstones
I haven't even been to the Ravenclaw
Tower oh my
failed
to luck have my exams but just wanted to
leave a like goodbye goodbye
thanks for tuning in appreciate the like
oh my Look At Me Now
the plan is to do more what if videos I
think it'll be fun
yeah I don't really shout out my
Instagram too much
um especially the Snape theories are
very interesting the what-if stuff is
also very interesting thank you
revelio I'm not really doing the
gobstones quest
honestly
um I followed in DM to be asking you law
questions yep you bet
yeah I know I can change how things look
have I ever thought about making a
Discord server
um I've thought about it yeah maybe
Maybe
it's on the list
I'd better keep an eye on high places
around the school for zenobia's
gobstones
revelio
foreign
hello hello
is that how you say it
yeah I'm just I'm just running around
guys
I'm not trying to do anything right now
when the [__]
Jim kovsky
how am I liking the game love the game
you won't be disappointed
it's me Gareth do you have a moment oh
someone said this is a good Quest
earlier who said that
are you calling me me Gareth I was
after you helped me with that fupa
feather and Potions I reckoned you might
be just the person I need you see I have
an idea for a fizzing whispy inspired
beverage but I'm missing a key
ingredient
you can change the appearance of the
gear you wear by the way
what are you implying
are you implying that
my character doesn't look okay
you and your concoctions I don't know
how you come up with these things it's a
gift truly so
I'd get them myself but my aunt Matilda
has her eye on me thinks I need to focus
on potions class for a while not for my
own bruise I was hoping you could follow
a secret passage to Honey thank you
thank you and grab a few dried Billy
wigs things for me he looks good
I wouldn't change a thing
it sounds simple enough and who wouldn't
want to go to honeydukes ah brilliant
thank you
I'll see what I can do Gareth no no
enough you shall be the first one to
taste my newest Brew if you can be of
help perhaps I can convince the meat to
help me with my potions homework get my
aunt to loosen is this Quest interesting
or should I use something else
I need to get those dried Billy wakes
things for Gareth if he's to fit his
latest concoction
the cloak looks cozy it does isn't it
you shouldn't be too hard to find
Rebellion
um yeah I like the Fantastic Beasts
Trilogy I don't think it's as good as
the other films but they're sort of
between 6.5 and 7 out of 10 for me I
knew this was all down here
do you like them
do you think the apologies potion will
come into this so you can change to
other people uh I don't think that's in
the game is it
be how I get down looks broken though
repair
okay yeah if there are any spoilers then
don't tell me no spoilers guys
seems to have done the trick
this game still isn't even out on a
bunch of consoles
I'm back sorry I left for a sec
um
didn't know you stream can't wait to
watch more thank you uh yeah it's kind
of new for me but
getting there
um secrets
spoiler-free Zone yep
so used to people hating on them I
enjoyed the third movie the other two I
did just didn't work my thing yeah I
agree the third one was my favorite
do you think is more powerful Voldemort
or Grindelwald you have to watch my
video on it Voldemort vs Grindelwald
who's more powerful
splits very cool you are streaming now
HPT or Silas so I've learned your name
tonight always enjoy your vids I'll try
and stop him when I can thanks for uh
stopping by yeah I'm gonna do more of
these I will say that but I've done
10 in the last month which is 10 more
than the previous four years so
so we'll never cease to surprise
good night splits
I'm trapped how am I supposed to get out
of here
revelio
I'm going to have to get past this
foreign
against the extension charm doesn't
exist yet no I guess not
one more to go and I'll make it across
repair
oh I didn't see that
what an idiot
love yourself something is getting in
the way of that platform
um no just chose gaunt randomly
uh didn't see the notification you
missed a few hours
what do I do here
perhaps I should cast accio to get that
frame out of the way first oh no that
wasn't good
damn
I tried Akio didn't do anything
I'm in uh Slytherin house
ah
yeah I thought I did that here I guess
not
Ikea
got it
very nice
this must be the way out I need to find
a way to open that gate
something smells sweet
close to honeydukes
oh pinstripe scarf let's let's have a
look
yeah I always use this at the wrong
spells as well
constantly
uh oh
that was interesting
okay well I guess I'm done for the night
um I was gonna stop soon anyway so
that's probably a good point to end
things
um did you know you can change your
clothing appearance yes yes everyone
keeps saying that
I know
uh the hagord meme hagord is
Like A Derpy version of Hagrid from the
PlayStation one Harry Potter game
[Music]
um
wish
Obi-Wan Kenobi hello there
that can happen if there was an update
yeah maybe that was what happened
um I think I'm done for the night guys
but
thanks for tuning in I think I will try
and be on again
tomorrow night I think that's the goal
tomorrow night yeah or possibly the
night after that but I think tomorrow is
realistic
yeah I'm not gonna change my outfit
staying the same
absolutely
okay guys have a good night everyone
talk to you soon okay bye